foreign
all right so we are talking about how to use the
Laplace transform to make pves simpler to solve
pdes specifically by LaPlace transforming
out one of the the independent variables
so that this partial differential equation
becomes an ordinary differential equation
uh one of these I have done this on the heat
equation this lecture I'm going to do it on
the wave equation and just to remind you you can
definitely solve these kinds of heat equations
and wave equations uh on infinite domains uh where
with nice boundary conditions where things Decay
to zero using the Fourier transform but if you
have a one-sided semi-infinite domain we need
to do it with the Laplace transform and we'll
need boundary conditions and initial conditions
so for the wave equation u t t the second
partial derivative of U with respect to
time equals c squared u x x the second partial
of U with respect to space uh here let me just
write down that U of x and t is basically going
to be the height of some rope so every kid when
you were younger right you like flipped a rope and
you know that sent traveling waves down that rope
so we're basically going to be shaking a rope at
the Left End and sending traveling waves down that
rope so this is uh position x equals zero it goes
to X you know tends to Infinity the Rope is being
shaken at one end which generates traveling
waves generates traveling traveling waves
and U of x and t is going to be kind
of the height or the displacement of
this rope at a location X at a time t so
this is essentially kind of the height
um height rope at X comma T at space at point
x at time t good and so now I need some initial
conditions and some boundary conditions and so
the first thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
say that I'm going to be shaking the Rope up and
down and I'm going to say that that's I'm going
to try to keep my boundary conditions blue so
I want to say that this up and down motion is
f of T some forcing in time so I'm going to say
that you at location x equals 0 for all of time
is equal to sorry it's so squeaky F of T this
is my boundary condition oh that's real squeaky
and then my initial condition is going to be
that at time 0 I'm going to have U of X at time
0 equals zero and I'm also going to have that
the derivative that it's not just at position
zero passing through with some velocity but then
it really has zero velocity that u x sorry sorry
u t u sub t at X at time 0 also equals zero so
the position is zero everywhere at Time Zero and
the velocity is zero at all locations X at Time
Zero these are going to be my initial conditions
and we're going to look we'll perform this PD
s and boundary conditions to get a solution okay
and again you always have to think to yourself do
I Laplace transform in space or in time because
the whole point here is that we are removing
one of these independent variables we're turning
it into a LaPlace variable which is essentially
going to be like a constant compared to the other
variable and so you have to decide am I LaPlace
transforming in time or in space and remember when
you Laplace transform something that has a second
derivative you're basically going to get um you
know s squared times that that function plus s
times the first derivative of the function plus
the second derivative of the function evaluated
either at zero yeah at zero and so whichever if
I have two boundary conditions or if I have two
initial conditions I'm going to use the one that I
have two of and Laplace transform in that variable
since I have two initial conditions in time and
two time derivatives if I Laplace transform in
time I'll have enough information to satisfy that
Laplace transform so you should actually try this
try to Laplace transform in space and you'll run
up against a wall pretty quickly because you won't
have enough boundary conditions so it's like a
good exercise I asked my students to do so we're
going to um maybe I'll I'll uh yeah I'll do this
right here
So we're going to Laplace transform in time...
So my markers are all squeaky becauseI've been here all day filming...
I hiked up from my home to the university with a guitar onmy back to do the wave equation lecture... now I'm doing Laplace transforms.
It is the evening... itis a holiday and my pens and I are both feeling very squeaky and dry...
but you know... I know thatmany of you are learning this material in nights and weekends... you have a full-time job
maybe youhave a family,
and you're learning this in your spare time.
and that's why I am teaching you in myspare time.
Because it matters and because you're putting in the time.
So we're going to Laplacetransform in time and we're going to use our two initial conditions hopefully to satisfythat initial data
in this Laplace transform.
and that's because I have two time derivatives
and two initial conditions so Laplace transform
in time is actually quite simple.
It's s^2 u-bar(x,s)
so remember u is a function of space and time
but I'm Laplacing in time, so now u-bar is a
function of x and my Laplace variable s.
My secondderivative in time became an s^2 * u-bar.
and then remember when you Laplace transform
something that has a second derivative you also
have a minus s times the first time derivative of
x at time zero this is kind of my first initial
condition at time zero minus uh U of X comma
zero equals c squared U Bar x x and remember
if I Laplace transform u x x with respect to
time that's the same as taking the second partial
derivative of U Bar my LaPlace of U with respect
to time you should just work that out on a little
napkin or piece of paper it's really simple if you
have a function of space and time I can Laplace
transform it in time and then take two partial
derivatives or I can take two partial derivatives
in X and then Laplace transform in time and
they're equal to each other so this is just U Bar
sub x x now the nice thing is is that my initial
conditions for this and for this are both zero I
did that on purpose obviously but it's a physical
scenario my rope started out you know I laid
it flat on the ground at zero and I'm going to
start whipping it that's a very physical initial
condition is that these are both zero so these are
zero by my initial conditions so that's super cool
right out of the gate we LaPlace transformed this
thing our initial conditions allowed us to kill
these two kind of pesky terms that always crop up
when you Laplace transform something with multiple
derivatives these kind of initial condition terms
and now I just have my equation s squared U Bar
equals c squared U Bar x x and this is an
ordinary differential equation in X this is
a second order linear ordinary differential
equation in X we know how to solve ordinary
differential equations because we got rid of
you know here we had two partials partial and
x and partial and Y and T here this only has
partials in X so it's an ordinary differential
equation so this is I'll just write that this is
an ode in in x and so we know how to solve this
ode in X using kind of you know simpler math pdes
are generally thought of as more complicated than
Odes it's more involved to solve them so this
should be easier to solve than this so let's let's
solve this uh expression here I think what I would
probably do is you know divide both sides by c
squared so I have U prime prime I'm just going to
write it out so I'm going to have like U bar x x
minus s squared over c squared U Bar equals zero
and so this thing is going to have eigenvalues
plus or minus root S over C and so those are
going to be the two basic Solutions are going
to be I'm just going to write it out here so
the two basic Solutions are going to be um
yeah the two basic Solutions are going to be U
Bar of X comma s equals an e to the Plus or an
e to the minus s over c x and an e to the plus
s over c x and these each have coefficients
out front there's going to be you know some a and
some B coefficients and just like when we did this
for the heat equation I hope you've seen that one
these coefficients are constants with respect to X
but that means that they can be functions of s
they can be whole transfer functions a bar of
S and B Bar of s and we're actually going to
determine these constants the these transfer
functions using the boundary condition here
that we haven't used yet so we already used our
initial conditions we're going to determine these
using our boundary conditions um good let's see
all right um and we know that when we flick this
rope it's never going to blow up to Infinity
like no one's that powerful maybe Thor if he
you know flicks a rope he can make it blow up
at Infinity but we can't and so this thing has
to Decay to zero as X goes to Infinity so that
right out of the gate kills this positive term
here so this term basically B has to equal zero
uh for a bounded solution and I'm kicking
myself because this should have been a blue
X and a blue writing because this is kind of
a boundary condition that it has to remain
bounded this should be blue b equals zero
okay unless you're Thor and so now this is
the only term in the solution super simple
right like we LaPlace transformed we used
our initial conditions this is the only
term that can be in the solution uh and
to some extent this is really easy because now
we're going to use this left boundary condition
where we set x equal to zero e to the zero
is one and so a bar s is equal a bar s
is equal to U Bar of x equals zero
comma s and U Bar of zero comma s is
just the Laplace transform of my forcing
F of T this U Bar is just the Laplace transform of
U at spatial location x equals zero at time T and
that's you know F of t so essentially u-bar at x
equals zero comma s is just the Laplace transform
of my boundary condition so this entire a bar s is
just my Laplace transform of my boundary condition
very very simple this is actually like an easier
example of Laplace transforms for pdes than the
heat equation maybe I should have started
with this one but I'm ending with this one
and so so the solution I'll just
write it here so the solution
the full solution in LaPlace domain is U Bar
X comma s equals you know um I'll call this
F Bar F Bar of s is just the Laplace transform of
my forcing F of T times e to the minus s over C
X that's it that's my solution this is my entire
solution to this rope being shaken one way kind of
semi-infinite domain wave equation now I'll have
to inverse Laplace transform this to get something
that has a Time variable instead of a LaPlace
variable that's a little bit tricky so this is
um in frequency in time I'm going
to get U Bar of X comma T equals
and you're going to have to take my word for
it that when you inverse Laplace transform this
construction here some function of s times e to
the minus s over c x essentially what this does
is it kind of time shifts this function so what
this is is this is f of t minus X over C you could
either compute this using the inverse Laplace
transform formula you could look in the back
of a textbook for you know the the lookup table
you could do this in you know Wolfram Alpha or
Mathematica you could derive this from scratch but
this is the answer is that this this expression
here essentially shifts the solution F of T by
you know X over C that's how much it shifts it by
and there's a detail here this function is only
defined I should have probably written this down
here this is only defined for T greater than or
equal to zero and X greater than or equal to zero
and so I have to multiply this by a heavy side
function and my heavy side function is T minus
X over C this is kind of a technical mathematical
detail the heavy side function uh literally I'll
draw you a picture of it but it's something
that only turns on when this is positive okay
because that's really important this argument
has to be positive um for this for this solution
so this is actually the honest to
goodness solution this is the solution uh
in time this is the solution in frequency domain
side means and I'm going to draw you a picture
of oh this is not a u-bar sorry you should be
screaming into your uh your screens right now
this is you not Laplace transform this is in
the original coordinates x and t is this thing
so I'm going to show you what this heavy side
function is and then I'm going to draw you a big
picture of kind of how information propagates in
a space-time diagram for this problem okay so the
heavy side function is pretty simple to visualize
um essentially I'm going to look at this heavy
side function and I'm going to first fix X and
very T and then I'm going to fix T and Vary X
and we're going to see what happens the heavy
side function is a function that is 0 when the
argument is less than zero when the thing inside
is less than zero it's zero and it becomes
one when the argument inside becomes positive
so it's like this and it kind of
jumps discontinuously at that location
so we're going to fix a and very
t so this is in the T Direction
and so this argument for a fixed X this argument
becomes positive and this heavy side jumps to
being positive when T equals X over C so at
some location basically there will be some
time X over C after which information will hit
that location X so there is a time before which
information doesn't reach a certain location
in X that's kind of what this heavy side is
saying is that it takes time for information
to propagate I'll draw you another picture
in a minute the other way to understand
this heavy side function is to fix uh uh t
and very X it's a little bit more complicated not
really if I fix T in very X this thing
becomes positive when x equals c times t
so similarly when x equals c times T this
thing will jump up and information will start
propagating at that location X so at a fixed time
at a fixed time there will only be certain X's
where information will have propagated oh I really
botched this is a the inverse of this because
sorry because this is a minus sign here it's X
less than CT where this is positive for X less
than CT this is positive and for X greater than
CT this is actually the argument is less than zero
and so my heavy set is actually like this when
I fix time and very X convince yourself of that
remember our heavy side function when this
argument is less than zero the heavy side is
zero and when this argument is greater than zero
heavy side is one and so if I fix T then for x
less than CT this thing is positive and
I have one and when it's greater than CT
this argument is negative and I have
my heavy set zero it's a little messy
but at the end of the day what we're trying to do
is solve this this PD the wave equation this is
the solution that's what you get when you when you
Laplace transform you use your initial conditions
you use your boundary conditions you get that it's
only this term in LaPlace domain this term right
here where F Bar is the Laplace transform of my
forcing my boundary condition and when you inverse
Laplace transform you get this weird relationship
that you get this shifted version of my my forcing
times the heavy side and my heavy side behaves
this way so now I'm going to draw you a picture
physically of what's happening and this is going
to make I think uh way way way more sense okay
so our forcing uh and I'll draw it in blue are
forcing F of T literally in time is going to be
some forcing remember you're a kid you're just
whipping this uh jump rope you know it's draped
out in front of you and you're just whipping
this thing at some you know F and you're trying
to make it as crazy as possible that's the F that
you're sending propagating through this this rope
okay so that that's F of T and so now what
we're going to do is we're going to draw
something called an x t diagram and this is used
all the time in physics especially in things like
shock wave physics or you know the propagation uh
soliton physics and Optics and lasers if you look
at shock waves in fluids like over a missile or
a bullet you're going to be drawing XT diagrams X
T and so now this forcing in time it's at location
x equals zero so it's at x equals zero x equals
zero in time this is my forcing function so I'm
forcing this thing at x equals zero at time T this
is my boundary condition forcing and essentially
what happens is along this characteristic line x
equals CT if x equals c times T this thing
is equal to zero and this is equal to zero
essentially what you find is that information
propagates in this x t diagram at a certain speed
so all of these kind of all of this
information propagates linearly like this
so what happens is if I go to a
downstream location X let's say I
go to this location you know X whatever
then at a certain time in the future
my initial forcing that I've already done is
appearing at that Downstream location X so that
forcing Position will essentially be traveling
down that rope this is it traveling down that
rope to farther and farther locations Downstream
to farther and farther X's as time progresses
as that information has time to travel down to
those Downstream locations so this is the line
this line here is super important and this basic
line here should be in a different color probably
this this line here that's kind of pink and
yellow this is the line x equals CT along
which information propagates so this is kind
of a characteristic we call this the wave front
or the characteristic line of
this problem and below this here
U equals zero because no information and so at
a really really really really far Downstream
location X you know 10 20 meters Downstream for
short times no information is propagated there so
it's still equal to zero until enough time has
passed that this initial wave front can reach
that location so this is the wave front this
is literally that like first part of the motion
when I just started turning this thing on at Time
Zero that is now traveling at this speed and that
forcing pattern is traveling Downstream on on my
rope really really important in capturing physics
traveling wave physics for the wave equation
pretty much the wave equation has what's known
as traveling wave physics that's where the word
wave comes from are these you know these waves
that are kind of coherent and traveling uh in
time with these XT diagrams okay so that's the
kind of intuition you can build when you solve
these things using the Laplace transform and you
can do it on weird domains so we are usually used
to thinking of infinite domains where X goes you
know negative infinity and positive Infinity
in which case if I forced my rope you know
in the middle of an infinite rope those waves
would travel both left and right I would get
waves going in both directions the two-way wave
equation until either you know it dies out at an
infinity or until it hits some kind of boundary
condition that's so far away that maybe it starts
reflecting back like maybe it's in the middle of
a gigantic guitar string or something like that
um so those are the kinds of things you can
play around with uh changing the boundary
conditions changing the size of the domain and
thinking about how these Solutions change but
this idea of an XT diagram this is why we
need the heavy side function literally so
that you know there are certain times at which
information will hit that X location and there
are certain X locations where the information
is zero until a certain time is is is reached
okay uh this is an example of how you solve
pdes with Laplace transforms to turn them into
Odes and then to use initial conditions
and boundary conditions all right thank you